Charlie Blackmon is here on the show how
you been charlie you bet do you want to
chime in on our football related poll
questions would you like to come along
at this point my fantasy team is winless
and I hope I'm not qualified to speak
okay so walk me through the Owen -
what's the name of your fantasy team we
are nasty
we are draft nasty okay oh okay and so
who is on this team
Charlie oh yeah we got junior who I had
hopes for at this point is
underperforming a little bit closer did
have a really great week I am you can
pumped up about LA and then we've
already had some some injuries wide
receiver in Seattle good points out up
anyway I got a long list of excuses at
this point okay so is this a league in
your Clubhouse is this Iraqis fantasy
league yeah just fun League with some of
my teammates
okay so who's leading it well it's like
oh Aaron Otto - and ours I mean what do
you got in it honestly it's a lot of a
lot of the pictures and bullpen guys end
up with lots of time for research and
they usually end up on top because they
just sit there do nothing right well no
I didn't say that that's not how it goes
because Charlie just you know I covered
baseball a lot before I did the NFL
thing it seems to me like like a
specialist in the bullpen it's kind of
like a punter or a kicker in the NFL you
know what I'm saying that they're just
there's they have one job and that's it
and and the rest of you like position
players every day players might think
that there
they're not there you know they're not
as is shall we say human you know what I
mean well the Coons on what perspective
you look at it from you know I think
baseball is becoming much more
specialized and no loser
there's players on the team who have a
very specific role he's a role players
and they do you know one thing doing
really well and sometimes it might just
be I get lefties out from the bullpen or
I come in put one inning in for as hard
as I can but I strike everybody out that
one you know and so you know from the
perspective of the everyday player it
looks like they have much less to do so
the perspective of you know somewhat
sitting at the class at home watching
the game like it's incredible that they
can you know show up game on the lines
and throw a first pitch slider right on
the black and you know and then perform
at that level with no build-up really it
was like in the fire right away don't
know it that was a very political answer
Charlie I mean that was it was
impressive I can't do you know like for
three hours would be completely what
tired after the game rather than have to
like put all my eggs in one basket and
hope that like I get blown for five
minutes like a Bolton yeah Charlie it's
hard to do Charlie Blackmon Rockies
centerfielder right here on the Rich
Eisen show you homered off for Clayton
Kershaw last night what is your approach
when you get into the box against the
lefty of his stature trying to strike
out you know I wish gets more
complicated than that but try and hit
the fastball I'll try to be prepared I
no one's gonna throw kind of I'm not
faced him a bunch I know this stuff
looks like but at that point it just
happen so fast
he's you know he's good you wanna look
like the whole game and say I need to
try and scratch out a hit or a walk you
know we need to push one run across here
maybe one there and it's really just
about
against the guy like that are you aware
of how far that ball went off of Kershaw
last night Charlie are you wearing that
so do you want a guest do you know how
far it went I think it went 430 feet
well if this is Price is Right rules you
would win your clothes without going
over it's 447 feet which is the longest
that's been measured off of Kershaw by
anybody since they started measuring
this stat in 2015 and you aren't even in
the Rocky Mountain air you're in the Los
Angeles smog man baseball season I
finally got a good swing
what is the Charlie Blackmon workout
regimen what is that it well it's pretty
intense I I do a lot of Douglas you know
I do I pretty much work out every major
muscle group in my body once every four
days and Jesus sometimes five days okay
once out of every four so it's sort of
like a rotation like a pitching rotation
I'll do I'll do an upper body workout
after the game and then like four or
five days later I'll do another body
workout you know but then I'll also do a
lower body workout and then I'll do some
like core strengthening and then I'll
just you know so there's a you know two
three four different work loss that I'll
do I'll make sure that I do you know
I'll do what about beard maintenance
Charlie what is that do you have a
regimen for that no there's not as much
work that goes into it you might put the
soap in it and I brush it out so it
doesn't get all knotty
are you serious I mean there's no
there's no scissors noted no no scaping
no nothing
it just is although I don't call except
for like once every
two months I get pretty well on its own
penny for itself you know sometimes I
get a little coconut oil in there
doesn't know the dry rocky mountain air
but if you're on a streak you don't
touch it right no that's just waiting
just you're I'm just seeing if you ever
wait for a certain moment before you
actually touch the beard you know lose
this point at which my mm-hmm that's a
moustache kind of gets really long it's
in the way of me trying to eat
hamburgers about yeah like more mustache
than hamburger that's usually what no
this oh my gosh Charlie Blackmon here on
the Rich Eisen show okay so how do you I
guess stay loose
when it's it's this is it I mean it's
time Dodgers are getting hot you need a
win tonight I mean you don't need to but
it would be helpful if you did I mean
how do you and your teammate stay loose
and something like this Charlie I don't
think you shy away from this you know
you even worth imposing your whole life
and at the same time you know I'm very
thankful I'm lucky to be able to be in
this situation where I get to go play
baseball and so I think it's kind of
that perspective helps me stay loose and
have fun but still understand that that
I worked really hard to get here and
then I want to do well and I want you
know I love that answer Charlie because
you know my my my youngest son has been
playing baseball playing Pony baseball
and he just loves putting on a uniform
and the cleats and the hat and running
out to his position in the field and I
would sit there just saying to myself
what must what does that feel like to be
able to do that professionally where
you're also handsomely paid for it what
in the hell does that feel like to be
able to put on a uniform and play a game
like baseball every single day
I you know I think if you change from
that pony lead kid and wind up you know
turning it into a job I think you're in
trouble you know I'm seen guys do that
but I think you still got to play the
game because you love it and in the best
players I see in my locker room another
lot of them are the guys just genuinely
loved the game you know if you really
enjoy baseball you're gonna you're gonna
hide the motivation to work out it be
good makes adjustments continue to play
one-on-one and all that yeah what do you
mean by making a job out of it because I
mean it's not like you're going up there
without any idea at the plate I mean
you're you're a professional you you you
are a pro what's the difference between
being a pro and making a job out of it
charlie get out at some point over the
course of a season of it over the course
of a career things are not gonna go well
I'm kind of how you react to it is is
very important and if you just turn your
emotion off and just say whatever I
don't care I'm just gonna get through
the season or whatever you know that's
when it becomes a job when you when you
stop caring when you stop enjoying the
competition when you start thinking
negatively because you aren't doing well
you know that it's really hard I mean
it's hard to go out there and get
dominated you know 70% of the time by
professional pitchers and and consider
that good you know so most of the time
it's more like 80% of the time you know
and so it's just you gotta still enjoy
the game and you got to be able to find
the silver lining and anything on the
baseball right in there do you have the
philosophy if you just want to take it
to the postseason you want you know cuz
you're you've got obviously the
Cardinals to contend with as well for a
wild-card spot I mean what's your
philosophy here on punching a ticket to
the postseason charlie I want to win the
division
setting the bar super high oh no but all
that stuff is good but honestly like as
a baseball player I think it's very
important to say I want to win tonight
if we win tonight I'll show up and then
I'll try and win tomorrow and I know it
sounds super Elementary but I think
that's the best way to play this game
day by day keep very short short-term
memory beam of the fees and then you
look up okay well I look forward to
seeing you play as baseball as long as
you want charlie I really enjoy watching
you play I was watching it with my kids
last night while you were going yard and
just I don't know you just I'm sure
you've heard this kids just look at you
and they just they're just root for you
I don't like just they could just see it
through the television set it's great
well that's great that's awesome I hope
they love baseball a little bit better
well we do again before I let you go
Trevor story how's he doing can you give
me any any two cents on on his health
availability sure Trevor got banged up
two nights ago on a on the throw and
then a swing his elbows bothering them a
little bit and all the good news come
back from his scan structurally it looks
like it's okay but he's pretty bummed
out but look wants back he's a tough guy
and I don't know what the time frame is
but I expect to see him back at some
point all right
well Charlie good luck over the rest of
the season it good luck to your fantasy
team if you ever need any advice you
know I'm sitting right here for you you
know I'm saying I'm here for you got it
you take care of Charlie Blackmon
Rockies center fielder Charlie Charlie
Blackmon Chuck underscore nasty na zt1
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience